Ngoa Tân như do chance nhà em và thằng từ đưa tin, lãnh tủ thưa khỏi ran môs tập à
khảm en này được cho là bị thương năng, cho cuộc tập tích ngày 20.2, với nhiều chân thương nghiêm
trọng. Một chân nên được phẫu thuật ba lần và ông ấy đang chờ lắp trên giả,
một bàn tay cũng được phẫu thuật. Mà đóng ấy bị vọng năng, rồi khó khăn chủ khoa chính nói
năng, và có thể sẽ cần phẫu thu thử thầm Mỹ. Ngoa chance giả lời các quan chức
iwan dấu tên chup biết, muon tên cũng khẳng định ông vẫn mình mắn và tích thủng giám
ra công việc, rồi đã tảm thời giao quen quy định cho các chính quyết thua lực lượng
vệ bình tích mạng của giảy iwan irogocsé bảo cũng cho biết với tất cả lãnh đạo iwan
hiện bị hạn chế nghiêm hạc, cho chỉ thị truyền đạt giữ sẵn phần bản. Chúc khi đảo
tổng thủng thủng vi đôi nân trang bài tỏ sử hoa nghi, bây giờ thông nhất trong lợi
bộ iwan cho rằng nước này đang gặp khó khăn chủ về sát định bộ máy lãnh đạo.
Tuy nhiên phía và báo bỏ nhận định này, thằng định sự đoàn các trong hủy thông chính trị,
và nhấn mạnh phai cho chỉ đạo của lãnh tụi tư theo. Lãnh tổng mô sức ba khảm ơn này là người có tà mạnh rủng sống giói
ran, ông không xuất hiện chứ công chúng, kể từ khi được mọi nghiệp, làm giấy lên nhau ý bản về tình trạng
sức khải của ông.